all praise is due to allah we thank him we praise him we glorify him we
beseech him to send his choices salutations upon his most beloved shalom
and upon all those who choose to tread in his path until the last day alhamdulillah
we're blessed to be together on this mubarak day of jummah may allah make us from
amongst those who gain from its benefits
both apparent and hidden
and where we are in a state still of physical separation our ability to maintain spiritual
connectedness
and to adapt
embrace change to still find meaning as is the nature of the believer
may allah make us from amongst those who
live through the prism of sound iman
the world in and of itself seems quite often to get heavier and heavier as days
turn to weeks and months
we find within the darkness and opportunity to be those people of real illumination real light
that share with others
at times of great difficulty
and today we have the distinct blessing where some of our amazing student leaders from nyu
are going to be sharing an initiative that they have been a part of over the
last few years called charity week with islamic relief
where they come together with thousands of muslim students across the world and show the power
of when we really engage in cohesive and strategic
convening
of how we're able to be a means of assistance
out of much greater
impact
their goal today is to help as many orphans and children
in need from all over the world
places like syria palestine
niger pakistan
young people who on a day to day struggle with great difficulty
but are now doing so in the midst of global pandemic in covet 19.
where and how we see others is not necessarily telling us so much about them themselves
but it gives us a lot of insight into who we are
and i want you to think deeply especially in this mubarak day of jummah
on what someone would have to look like in order for you to not be there
for them
what qualities what conditions would they have to come with
what part of the world what country would they need to reside in
in order for us to justify and validate
an absence of support for them in their time of need
our prophets
who many of us have been blessed to be privy to gatherings in this month of
where people are recounting the prophetic biography
hadith that give insight into his beautiful and amazing character stories and narrations that and live
in our spirit and give us a state of invigoration and rejuvenation
because we are drawn to his ethics his values
we love him
because of who he is
but he loves each one of us
as he is a representative of the divine himself
but the prophet's love for us distinct for our love for him
as allah's love for us
is a love because of who
they are not necessarily who we are
it's without condition without qualification
a love that embraces us in all of our diversity and accepts us despite our imperfections
just as any perfect love would
and through that love and that compassion
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam lived altruistically and selflessly
epitomizing
giving and generosity to the highest of levels
i would ensure that he would be with people in their struggles
and if you have an attachment to him
you want to break down why and where it comes from
and to love those qualities that are embodied in just one person
has another step that says that we too can carry out those qualities and manifest them
within
ourselves
a gift of a goat one comes to the prophet's house
and he does not indulge in it in any way he does not take for it
from himself
it's a gift it's not sadaka it's not charity he's allowed to
but his first inclination is to give what he can from it to his companions who
are more in need
and his wife
when she sees that all of it is left but its shoulder
or none of it is left but its shoulder
she says that it's all gone except the shoulder
to understand the magnitude of this generosity you can't look at hadith in isolation of one
another but you have to see how they all connect to each other
because we have narrations in the prophetic tradition that say that days would go by without
a fire being lit in the home of the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because he had nothing to cook on the fire there was no food to cook on
a fire so there's no point for a fire
he would wrap rocks to the waist of his body
to balance himself out from the sheer weight loss that he had from not eating so
much
and now when a gift of a goat comes to his home
and he can take from it whatever he wants
and this is a person who does not eat so much at all
he still gives to others
before taking for himself
and when his wife
says that
all of it is gone except its shoulder
the beloved of allah
to her and says that all of it is there for us except the shoulder
what a beautiful way to see the world
that paradigm shift comes from within it's not a vision that is simply of the eyes
but a vision of the heart
and to recognize and understand that we are now talking about children orphans young boys and
girls people who are entitled to live the life of contentment pursue aspiration just like any
one of us
but circumstances define and dictate what they can have access to and what they cannot
in ways that are quite unique in comparison to how some of us live
generosity and altruism becomes a key link to contentment for the giver
that when you engage in acts of kindness and acts of beauty the benefit
comes back to oneself
and if you think about it fundamentally which heart do you want do you want the
heart that knows of a person a young child in need and does not do what
you can to support them
or do you want the heart that commands the rest of the body to dig deep
and not think of reasons as to why there might be excuse to not give that
we are not of the same race we are not of the same ethnicity we are
not of the same culture i just gave to something yesterday i just did something a
week ago i need to be able to buy this or own this or possess this
which heart do you want
and the cultivation of that heart stems from doing the acts that will then yield the
clarity internally and create over and over and over
so the verse is true
that is the reward for exam anything other than that beauty creates beauty creates beauty goodness
yields goodness
and that becomes external that your act of kindness your active beauty will then perpetuate more
acts of kindness and beauty but also if we think about it internally the doing of
beauty will then create more beauty within you that the vehicle for the increase in a
value is the value in it of itself so you want to increase in goodness you
got to be good
you take advantage of openings and opportunities that are yielded for your benefit and gain
and so when our young people speak to you right now our amazing student leaders listen
from your heart and open all of your organs of sensory perception
try to see what it is that they are telling you try to listen from your
ears and command your entire body to be in a space where it is now not
yielding to the ego the nufs
but in the true sense of real empathetic love you suspend the ego the nufs and
everything that feeds and fuels it and you try to understand the experiences of the other
simply through their lived realities
and so we're gonna have a few of our students share some words
after which i'm going to come back and close with some thoughts and end in dua
and so i would ask that all of you be as present as possible and where
you are able to give
we will put the links in the various platforms that we are on so that people
are able to contribute to this amazing initiative to help children and orphans in need and
so our first student that's going to speak is our brother kumail who many of you
know he is the president of the muslim students association
at our washington square campus we have 13 msas at new york university mashallah
and kumail is the head of the msa and our main campus as well as a
member of the charity week committee
and so kumail if you want to turn your video on and get started inshallah and
then we'll pass it on uh when you're wrapping up your comments just pass it on
to the next speaker if you can
say mom thank you so much for your really beautiful words i meant for the introduction
as well what's up alaikum everybody my name is komal and i like monk mentioned i'm
a student at nyu um i'd like to begin just take a couple minutes of your
time today um but just to begin with some some ayats from
the translation of these verses in the name of allah the most beneficial the most merciful
indeed the virtuous will have a drink a pure drink flavored with camphor from a spring
where allah servants will drink blowing at their will they are those who fulfill their vows
and fear a day of sweeping horror and give food despite their desire for it to
the poor the orphan and the captive
when i think of the topic for today contagious generosity
my mind goes to the discussion that we had last night during the icu moment and
really some of the beautiful words that had just mentioned
and our love for the prophet extends beyond just the words that we do and the
actions that we have but it's really a love that transforms us to love that changes
you it's a love that inspires you to do much things for the better i asked
myself how can i reflect these qualities in my own life am i someone that does
mirror lip service and my allegiance to the prophet or do i allow it to be
something that transforms me to do better
if the prophet was the exemplar of generosity himself but how can i model my lifestyle
my thoughts and my beliefs after his own
as mom called mentioned the prophet was a person who used to tie stones to his
own stomach in order to counteract the effects of his weight loss he's someone who lived
by the words that he preached
so i asked myself if i'm somebody that can live up to that same example
as those ayats of that son that i just read have reminded us generosity isn't something
that's just a recommendation in islam it's not something that i can do when it's convenient
or when the time is right but it's a hallmark and it's a virtue of the
righteous ones it's one that's a characteristic of those who are granted this high station
that generosity is not something that we do for the sake of fulfilling the ego or
giving ourselves a pat on the back but it's truly to uplift the other beautiful creations
of allah around the world and being in that position is really a big privilege to
be able to do so
my mind goes to lady khadija islam one of the richest people in all of the
arab tribes at the time but when the call comes she gives it all for the
sake of allah i ask myself if i'm a person that believes that feasts have either
left as she did or if i'm just someone that's seeking to feed my own ego
it's easy for one to say that they're generous or that they do good things that's
another thing when all the odds are stacked against you
this past december and january i had the opportunity to go on a zero trip to
iraq with the islamic center and for those of you who don't know after the effects
of the iraq war 2004-2005
they left around 800 000 orphans in the country
and it's really a really really sad sight to see when you visit there on the
streets there's orphans begging everywhere they'll come up to you they'll tug at your clothes and
they'll ask you for money or they'll ask you for help
you know as someone that's not used to seeing this it's a really painful experience especially
because you're advised to not help all of them because they often swarm in crowds and
things like that
when my brother went on trip a couple of years ago he said that when they
visited an orphanage
the people who ran the orphanage told them that they're having a lot of problems recently
because the common consensus around these kids was that they would more much rather be on
the street making money from asking for people from charity we're just selling small things and
going to school and getting an education
and the thing that's really sad about this is that the burden falls on all of
us these eight hundred thousand the purest of souls these children who grew up without parents
in the country that was devastated by the effects of war and now in a country
that's wracked by that and by the effects of nineteen
it's really just a painful reminder of the state of the world today i know surely
those parents of souls will be raised to the prophet on that day in which we'll
all be seeking shelter
but the biggest takeaway i took from that trip and upon seeing all these orphans is
that when one of us is hurting we're all hurting that pain that i felt in
my heart when i saw these orphans roaming the streets with nothing to do and nobody
to help them it reminded me that it's a call of act call to action
how can i forget the example of the prophetic um that he strove his entire life
to help build i should inspire myself to the standard creating a community of generosity is
not something that we can do when it's convenient but it's rather something that's a constant
way of life it's something that transforms us in our very actions our relationships about creating
systems of change as well
and that although humans at times are often built with that individualistic mindset it's about really
breaking out of that tribalism building more into collective mindset in which we're all part of
the same unity
we're all one community under the eyes of god yes we have differences but as the
prophet said in his farewell sermon that there's no superiority amongst you between arabs and non-arabs
between black and white or other skin colors except those who have piety
our attributes of god consciousness are a uniting factor above all else
and truly generosity is beloved by god it's the biggest reminder of his existence
i would like us all to inspire one another with our attributes of kindness and generosity
but it doesn't start with just giving money or giving charity it starts with being generous
with our love with our care for each other the time we spend in each other's
company actively listening to each other these are all acts of generosity
the prophet was the one person who would spend the most time listening to each other
it wasn't always just financial generosity the thing that matters starting a meal with somebody that
doesn't have anyone to eat with or just speaking to somebody that you know is going
through a tough time those are all simple acts of generosity that create transformation from within
so i encourage you all to help help each other out it doesn't always have to
be from
a sense of financial support obviously conditions aren't the same for everyone but generosity can come
through the form of not diminishing the accomplishments of other people uplifting each other when we
have the opportunity to and thinking of others in our time of need
the way to becoming a community of generosity is to treat others with compassion above all
else
if we don't purify the way we treat ourselves and really follow the example that the
prophet has set for us that we won't become a community of generosity in its fullest
sense
so i just like to leave you all with one more reflection from my time in
college but you know as students that can often feel that there's nothing i can do
beyond the way i talk to people in the way i treat people and helping others
around the world it often feels very helpless and that i'm not able to be the
one to go and help other communities that need it i see images of war all
the time there's destruction happening all across the country from systems of inequity that are perpetuated
throughout time whether it's based on race whether it's based on gender or whether it's based
on religious class
especially with the effects of covenant 19 this past year i've really seen this just be
accentuated and that feeling of helplessness has grown even more
especially with the pandemic i've seen my father was working in the hospital during the entire
time seeing him at the front lines and me feeling as if i couldn't really do
anything to help people it kind of takes a toll on you
but one thing that really helped stand out is having the opportunity as students to be
empowered having having that opportunity to be involved in different things
one thing that i've really had the opportunity to be blessed with last year and this
year alhamdulillah is the charity week initiative so for those of you that don't know charity
week is
it's a global initiative that happens in coordination with islamic relief with universities across the country
that goes towards different causes whether that's helping orphans and children in syria in lebanon in
niger in gaza and in other places around the world
and really the most beautiful thing about charity week is that students across the world no
matter where they come from what language they speak what they look like level of religiosity
that all does not matter in this week it's truly a week in which these embodi
this these virtues of community and generosity are really embodied
and i've really found it to be a way that as a student i've been able
to find my voice and it's been a time in which i've been able to see
that the work we do really has an impact
so i encourage you all if you're able to in any way every donation really matters
and i encourage you all if you have the means to do so please please donate
with all of your heart and that would it's just the first step in building that
prophetic community that we have been talking about all these days
um now i would like to pass it off to us who is also a student
at nyu and she's been a very active member of the charity week committee and has
been doing a lot of really great work masha allah so asthma whenever
thank you so much kamel and imam khalid um
for those lovely words um my name is asma i'm a junior at nyu and i
am on the msa board as well as the charity week committee and i just want
to ask you a couple of questions before we get started um
do you right now have a roof over your head do you have food on the
table did you eat breakfast this morning
do you have a job or a source of income all of these questions might seem
like kind of you know like oh those things are obvious and we just take them
for granted um but with this pandemic and just in general those things are really really
really important and they're not given to everyone equally and having those things is a privilege
even having family around us is a privilege there's so many people out there who are
alone who are orphans who don't have any family um having that companionship having someone to
quarantine with like is such a privilege so i want to start by saying that just
being here um having a roof over your head having food having a stable wi-fi connection
to watch this beautiful um jummah reflection is a privilege in itself so talking about privilege
um these orphans um and children all across the world do not have the same thing
or the same access as we do and it is our duty as muslims to support
them and to help them um and i was going to go into more of an
explanation of what charity week is but komael already did that so beautifully but um one
of my favorite parts about friday is which is a chapter in the quran it's recommended
that we read it on fridays and i really try to read the surah as well
as reflect on its meaning every friday um so suda gaff has four stories um i
just like to highlight one really quickly today um one of the stories is the story
of the two gardens so the story highlights two men who had beautiful gardens like filled
with fresh fruit and vegetables and there was a beautiful river in between the gardens you
know it was very prosperous um one garden was a little bit more prosperous than the
other but both were still doing well so both of these men had sustenance and they
were privileged in their own way um but one of the men um started kind of
bragging to the other man or kind of saying like oh look i have more than
you my i have more men than you i have more resources than you um and
the other man warned him he said um
you know you shouldn't say that um because this is all from allah um this is
not of your doing i mean obviously we do work hard to get where we are
in life but everything we have is from allah and the other man proceeded to say
well i don't believe in that like i don't believe that the day of judgment will
come like you know even when the world ends i will still have my garden i
will still have my riches i also have my gold etc um and the man's um
garden and everything perished um it was all gone in a split second i mean not
like a split second but it was all gone um and that is when he believed
and i want to i want to bring up this story because the little things that
we have are so important and we often take them for granted and we think it's
because of our own doing we think it's because you know i worked hard on this
and i stayed up all night doing this um and yes that does contribute to it
but um it is also the privilege that allah gives us to go to school as
camilla was saying all these orphans don't even want to go to school because they want
to make money on the streets i mean alhamdulillah i didn't even have to think about
that as a kid um i just went to school because i had food on the
table i had a home to come home to parents to come home to so that
is a certain privilege that we have and we must um realize that that's from allah
and in order to thank allah for what we have we have to be generous with
others who don't have the same um it's just so heartbreaking to see these videos if
you go onto the charity week website and you see videos and images of these kids
and islamic relief which is um uh they're a partner of charity week um giving out
these packages to these kids and the smiles on their faces it's just like so beautiful
to see um and this like sense of unity that we all have with all the
msas all around the world like literally any every country you can think of is participating
in charity week um so it's just really um a beautiful week i've enjoyed being a
part of it for the past three years of college and even though it's virtual this
year i feel like this pandemic has made it more urgent um and more important than
ever um so please donate if you can um but if you can't i it's all
good like i know that it's a hard time for everyone but every time you share
a launch good in a group chat or on your facebook or on your instagram it
is much much more likely to get donations so it really um please ask you to
do that it's on the msa instagram page and facebook page um we've also sent it
in the zoom webinar if you're watching from zoom um but yeah so thank you all
so much for your time jamaa mubarak and i'm gonna pass it on to amalia who
is another student
thank you so much um that was really great um asma and kumal and iman quality
for all of your words so i recently started volunteering with icnyu a little bit before
kovid
and recently with nyu msa and i just saw how the all of these charity work
that actually inspired me to start donating more and getting more it inspired me to reconnect
with islam as well because i realized that this volunteering is a huge pivotal theme in
islam and the quran
and so
recently i came across this very beautiful verse that i want to share with you all
um it's
start with that first um and it is verse number
um wait let me make sure yeah it's verse 265
um and it goes like this and the example of those who donate their wealth seeking
allah's pleasure and believing the reward is certain is that of a garden on a fertile
hill when heavy rain falls it yields up twice its normal produce if no heavy rain
falls a drizzle is sufficient and a lot is all seeing of what you do so
the way i interpreted this verse is that one charity is the sake of is this
is only for allah and no worldly gain should be of course when you are donating
it should be from your own personal and pure intention um and as everyone mentioned already
that before touched upon um the concept of charity for the sake of allah only and
i would usually attend like so many lectures that would talk about like you know doing
things for the sake of allah like what does this mean right it's so hard to
embody that because you know especially being someone who's like very like i'm very competitive and
ambitious and so i think like breaking away from like my ego and my nufs and
like just doing something for the sake of god is hard you know it's hard to
reach that point um but what helps me is thinking about our nabi right thinking about
rasulullah prophet muhammad made peace be upon him we all know he had so much compassion
and generosity right so it's actually no surprise that he had a discomfort with having too
much wealth um and so there's this other story that i came across um recently as
well that i will share with you a short story um that i think is so
beautiful and made me fall in love with our nabi even more um so it goes
like this so one day like prophet muhammad made peace be upon him he was looking
very like he was like disturbed and this was reported by um
so he was looking like really disturbed and then she uh acts like what's wrong and
he replied that there were seven dinars so dinars were the gold coin that was used
in like um during that time um that was the currency in a lot of um
the middle east and south asia that was the currency at the time um in the
seventh century and medieval islamic empires so basically like think of it like seven dollars basically
um were still like on the table and hadn't been distributed and so um this large
sum of vault was received in tribute from bahrain and so rasulullah um ordered the money
to be spread in the camp in the compound of the mosque and after the prayer
he basically distributed all of the money and every person that came to the mosque he
gave them that money and he gave so much to abbas
as well that he was unable to get up from the weight when nothing was left
um he shook off his cloak and got up so subhanallah this story depicts that he
had our nabi had a discomfort from having too much wealth
and when i think about this story the way i would relate it to like our
own lives and like our modern day what's going on like today like we all like
obviously we look we want success right like we go through college and um we do
these internships and jobs all for the very purpose of gaining money um but we forget
to like give back and even when we do give back and donate we kind of
are hesitant to like give to a cause right like we're very skeptical um for many
different reasons right like sometimes we don't have enough or we simply at the moment do
not feel like giving um and i think reaching that state of being so selfless to
the point that you're not a skeptic and that you give from your heart the way
i would go about that is thinking about our beloved prophet muhammad may peace be upon
him put yourself into his shoes and think what would he do in this situation
um we see pictures of children all the time where you know we see uh like
children struggling in syria lebanon right there's so many there's so much poverty in the world
um and i think sometimes people think oh like my donation is not going to matter
it does matter even your three dollars matters that someone's meal like somewhere else in the
world and i worked with non-profits um uh recently on like irc and anera.org and i
partnered up with them and i saw firsthand like how our donations actually helped families start
their business we were able to hire tutors so that children could um you know learn
english and refugees and help them so our donations are impactful um and i think another
question well i'll end it off um now i'll like stop talking um and um after
this uh because i'm talking way too much um but i'll say what i'll say is
the takeaway from all of this is that number one it is our responsibility already as
muslims to be giving and number two um to i would say the biggest takeaway is
to remember our beloved prophet muhammad may peace be upon him whenever we are feeling like
our ego is getting the best of us or that we even when we're feeling down
and we and we don't have enough allah makes it a promise in the quran that
he is going to give you more and finally number three that although we are helping
these orphans and children they're actually helping us so we might be helping them in this
dunya but they are building our akhira um so yeah that's what um i would say
the three
takeaways
thank you all so much for sharing these amazing words and just as we close to
recognize again that the opportunities for you and i i've been in numerous conflict zones i've
been in refugee camps have been in parts of the world that have been impacted by
natural disaster
and when you look into the face of families individuals widows orphans the elderly people who
have been devastated in their lives and they don't have so much
what we give to them is not just what is fundamentally one of the most important
things that someone can gift to someone that we quite often consider it to be an
inconsiderate gift which is money but for many people that becomes the most practical and important
thing that we can actually give to them especially those who are in a place of
need
you're also gifting to them the sense that they're not forgotten they're remembered that there's somebody
who's thinking of them in a world that seems to have left them alone
and so where you can contribute it would be deeply important
i once was in a refugee camp where people were in mass exodus fleeing
ethnic cleansing and genocide
and one day when we were walking through the camps in the morning
over a hundred children on their own walked into the camp with nobody else there with
them
we had no idea where they came from we didn't know their families
and later on in the day there was a young girl who was running around where
we were shooting footage and taking pictures
this young girl she almost fell off of a cliff into a deep valley where we
had situated ourselves and we all went to grab her and put her to the side
and once we had gotten her settled i asked who is this and why is no
one looking after her
when we realized that she was an orphan from amongst these child refugees
her reality was not just that she had no mother or father
but as an orphan of the conflict that she was fleeing
her circumstance was different
because there wasn't a person alive who could tell us anything about her
no one knew her name no one knew her age her birthday
they have no idea what part of the country she had fled from and where she
would then go
and there's so many young kids who are like this in the world right now
and what muslim students are doing all over the world at this moment is engaged in
this initiative of charity week
to help children in need to help orphans in need
so that they are not forgotten and when you look into the face of somebody who
otherwise has no one thinking of them
what we're giving them is a sense of strength a sense of courage
when allah elevates us to a makama station to be the means through which he does
not simply feed clothed and give shelter to his creation
but he makes us a means through which he gives strength hope courage
bestows mercy and love upon his creation
that's not a station you want to be without
and so please support what you can insha allah allah will return to you many fold
beyond what it is that you will contribute
and as asma had said when you share the links in your networks you repost it
you share it on whatever social media you have the average gain per share is another
36 dollars
and 36 dollars in other parts of the world can go a really really long way
and for people who sometimes don't make that in a month
two months four months
can make all of the difference
on this blessed day of jummah please do give what you can inshallah
reward you immensely for it
this coming week is going to be a very important time the election in this country
and i encourage each and every one of you to make sure that you go out
to vote
that you can start now november 3rd is not the first day of voting it's the
last day of voting
so whether by mail you go to the early voting lines make sure you are doing
it
the islamic center is going to be hosting the day after the election a community space
online a healing space a support space
that we know regardless of the outcome many of us have been carrying a lot of
heaviness and feelings within us so whether you are a student an alumni a faculty a
staff member one of our beloved community members of the islamic center at nyu we invite
you to join us in that community support space and you can find more information on
that on our website they'll be taking place the day after the election next week we
want all of you to join in even if you are doing okay to be a
means of support for others who are likely going to need a lot of healing and
can lean even if virtually on all of us to help them get through the difficult
emotions that they're experiencing at this time
in a few weeks we're going to be hosting a weekend retreat with shikha aisha prime
virtually
called the path to peace it's meant to be a means through which people recognize their
own spiritual development and how to bring ease to their inward and that'll be taking place
on the weekend of november 13th so please do look out for that you can go
to our website right now and sign up for it we've already got a ton of
people who have registered because again the time is quite heavy and difficult and people know
that there's strategy
in our tradition that builds into it the opportunity for spiritual gain and healing
and the week after that shakespeare webb will be doing another weekend program this would be
on concepts of end of life matters death and dying within our tradition
and we recommend that you all join there as well and lastly a dua request that
came in in the midst of this program
our brother muhammad malek who is a brooklyn law school graduate
who had married recently a sister noor shah who is a graduate of nyu med school
they had gone to the bahamas for their honeymoon and we receive news that unfortunately
both in some kind of uh occurrence uh passed away as a result of drowning while
they were there on their honeymoon so we would ask that you keep them in your
dua that allah showers upon them his infinite bhakthira raises them from amongst the shahada grants
them peace in their graves and entrance into jannah without any judgment and brings ease to
all of us who have lost loved ones and have felt that pain in any way
but please do keep them and their families in your prayers inshallah allah will accept it
from us if you join me in closing and making a dua
as we wrap up this jummah reflection
like
we begin this supplication in your name ya allah and beseech you to send your choice
of salutations upon your most beloved sallallahu ta'ala
we ask that you shower your infinite mercy upon this gathering granting each and every one
who is present herein and our loved ones only the best in this world and the
best and the next we ask that if all of us are meant to be together
only at this time at this place whether we are young or old male or female
regardless of our race our ethnicity our social class our country of origin our cultural heritage
whether we are muslim or come from a different walk of life ya rabbi if our
individual hearts are meant to be in the presence of all of their hearts that are
gathered here only at this time at this place then gather us all together again in
the best of places in the world beyond this one increases
that is good increase us encourage compassion and confidence protect us from any affliction anxiety or
anguish remove from our hearts any feelings of bitterness jealousy animosity or envy towards any of
your creation grant us hearts that find themselves in a state of tranquility and calm hearts
that are drawn towards goodness and beauty hearts that are deep in your remembrance for indeed
in your remembrance to hearts find rest we ask outlaw that you make us a means
through which benefit is brought to your creation and you help elevate this community and everyone
who has gathered at this occasion
to be a means of support for all children all orphans who are in need in
this world grant success to our students in their endeavors and make them from amongst the
best of your righteous servants who live in pursuit of selflessness not selfishness sincerity and never
self-centeredness
make us
from amongst those who are not scared to ask you
to make us those who only do that which is good remove from our lives anything
that distracts us and make us a means through which goodness and beauty illumination
is brought to this world that at times feel so heavy and dark through us ya
allah feed your creation through us
clothe your creation through us give shelter to your creation through us give strength to your
creation through us give hope to your creation through us be generous to your creation through
us be merciful to your creation through us love your creation
and help us to find a self-love that enables us to go out and live to
our very best of potential every day rather than a love of ourselves that keeps us
feeding our own incessant wants at the expense of our needs and the needs of those
around us
protect us always from hearts that are not humble tongues that are not wise and eyes
that have forgotten how to cry forgive us for our shortcomings and guide and bless us
may allah bless you and your loved ones always and give you nothing less than the
best in this world and the best and the next i hope you all are keeping
well and staying safe insha'allah please do go out and vote and join us in the
programs that are coming and where you can please do support our students in this initiative
and make dua for them and thank allah that they have been a means through which
we can perform these good deeds and goods acts
who